That's the basic HTTP request, now let's talk
a little about HTTP responses. Let's talk about where
we are first. You've got you and your machine
and you've got these servers. Your browser makes a
request to the servers, and your server sends
back the response. We talked about the requests already,
and the server responds with, a response, the document
that you requested or, you know, information about the
document depending on what you requested. A basic HTTP response
looks actually very similar to the request. For a basic
request that looks like this, the response might look something
like this. Okay, so we can see a couple easy
things. First of all the stat, this is called the
status line. And this is analogous to the request line
we had over here. Now the version of the status
line matches the version of the request line, and then
it's followed by two other pieces of information. One is
the status code and the other is the reason phrase. And
this is just an English language description of the status
code. There are some really common status codes and I'll I'll
show you some of them here. 200 OK, that means,
the document is found. This is a far and away the
most common status code on the internet and hopefully we'll be
seeing a lot of these. 302 found that means the document
is located somewhere else. 404 not found you've probably seen
this one a lot, this means the document wasn't found.
And 500 server error, that means the server broke trying
to handle your request. Unfortunately we will probably also be
seeing a fair number of these in our adventures in
this course. Status codes basically begin with one, two, three,
four or five. If it begins with a two, it
basically means success, if it begins with a three, it basically
means we need to do something different
technically to find this document. Four means there
is an error on the browser side,
requesting a document that doesn't exist, for example,
and five means there's an error on
the server side, such as, the server's broken.
Okay, let's let's move on a little bit and talk a little more about responses.